bien et maintenant pour qu on est serrés
pas un nouvel exercice ravis que tu aies
pu nous rejoindre sky j'arrive en retard
à mon enterrement
faites une liste des choses que vous
aimeriez faire je ne sais pas quoi
écrire écrit n'importe quoi les
autochtones ce bientôt tu vas mourir
tout va très bien kalfin
ouais il vous fait quoi de mes symptômes
vos problèmes de santé ne sont pas
physiques j'ai que sortir un truc
bizarre
crois qu'elle est trop bien pour moi
elle est route ou pour toi je m'appelle
easy sommes d'accord donc on commence
dès demain on commence quoi malice de
truquer faire tout ce que j'aimerais
faire avant de mourir
[Musique]
ces peurs la victoire heureuse et quand
il disparaît tu me manques
c'est pas drôle ouais galli tout ça
c'est un jeu pour toi je vais mourir
alors tu veux que je fasse quoi que je
m'habille tout sur mon sort c'est déjà
fait ces examens n'ont rien donné tout
ça ça se passe dans sa tête
personne ne mérite de vivre ce que tu as
vécu mais au moins tu as la fille devant
toi alors faisant quelque chose ce que
tu veux
elle n'est pas aussi forte a mal au
genou pas la voir mourir
arrête de penser à toi pense à elles et
que tu sens ouais ben je suis en vie
titre papa génial